Patricia what's going on I'm dying
and fellow HIV cancer but chess to
Israel and to the strokes yes bro to
throat two strokes yeah you know my
fellow Aussie breast cancer breast
cancer some and in your hiv-positive
yeah
how do you ever HIV nice so I and you
have some [ __ ] up to me yes actually
well now sleep the an sinks me so
telling my story now she lets go tell a
story
so as we they're gonna cut me off
oh no coming off you go it's right to I
buy already already so I get real sleepy
it [ __ ] so we'll see what time away to
this time there you go see in Co tired
too
so I know I'm gonna get 3334 you smell
first
[Music]
are you process this
you guys using here no I using
sometimes dress please yeah so we'll see
what's our way
see No
[Music]
tell me what story
I see
as he
[Music]
if you got to you have
I would love you to be a man in place up
there this is bad places you can fine
yeah
[Music]
thank you
good boy all right Patricia how are you
okay so what's the latest um Jerry 18
January teens you're gonna start with
Kela dari therapy good for you good for
you because you were debating whether to
do that or not right yeah I'm gonna
doing it so when you wake up in the
morning do you go I can't believe this
is happening to me
what kind of classes go through your
head when you're scared scared sure yeah
okay 34 Madhu was still friends
thank you and I my HIV of HIV and [ __ ]
know I'm Megan breast cancer no I found
out yesterday I'm negative because I was
ten states a friend but is he for having
sex with a girl fade ready girlfriend
yeah she is yeah
did you seem did you get it yeah yeah
okay
so HIV negative breast cancer stage
three I'm sorry January 18 s argued
theory I'm ready
thank you thank you
thank you for don't I get you